Alright guys, so here is the example number two. So as you can see I'm at here at 9.55 and we do
not have a clear liquidity sweep here. Okay, so what we can do now, so if you didn't know this before,
you know, these PD areas are drawn on liquidity as well. So it could be a fair value gap, right?
And essentially when you are marking the fair value gap, the last candle of the fair value gap
is basically a liquidity on a smaller time frame. So if I go back to like one minute, you can see
that this is a low right here. So we're going to wait for price to take out this low and this is
our sell site liquidity taken out, right? And then we wait for a clear market structure shift
inside like, you know, the internal market structure. So you can see that we have this
high over here. And if it breaks, that is perfect. And as you can see, it broke, right? Now,
here's the thing, if this structure broke here, right, then I will consider this the more structure
it breaks, the less the chance of that setup playing out. Okay, remember that. So we have a
beautiful structure break here. I couldn't I could consider this as a structure break as well.
And now we have our fair value gap. We take our entry here, put our store bright blue. Actually,
let's go for five handles right here. And our take profit five handles as well. And let's see how
this plays out. And you can see we had our take profit level. And if we held the trade, you can
see it kept going up, potentially up to 1.75. And then we reverse back and stopping us out. So,
this is how you can trade. Essentially, you would have gone for one to one as ICT says. Okay,
but I usually go for one to two, I would I would have gone like break even once that
restore what was hit. So this trade would have been a break even for me. But you can see if you put
your stop at five handles, or maybe let's go, if we actually put if we let's ignore the five
handle thing, right? If I put my stop right below the slow, and if we went up, we would have easily
gotten a two restore wall trade. But as I said before, we would have gotten stopped at break even.
So yeah, that's that was it for this example. Let me give you guys one last example.